cédric robert bonjour vous êtes le
coordinateur de l'opération covit pour
la croix rouge 78 quelles sont vos
activités aujourd'hui en cas de pandémie
l approche d un française des yvelines a
été mobilisé plus d'une dizaine de jours
sur cette opération qu'ovide 19 au
travers de différentes actions alors au
quotidien on assure déjà des activités
d'action sociale qu'on nous avons revu
réaménagé pour mettre en place des
protections pour nos bénéficiaires ou
nos bénévoles
donc nous allons maintenir quatre
activités principales au niveau de
l'action sociale qui sont la
domiciliation l'aide alimentaire
l'accueil de jour et les maraudes donc
compenser les activités avec bien
entendu des mesures bien particulière
qui sont mis en place pour protéger les
bénéficiaires et les bénévoles
on a aussi depuis une dizaine de jours
renforcer le salut avec un appui sur la
cellule téléphonique du samu notamment
sur la gestion de sms et depuis aussi
une dizaine de jours on met à
disposition une ambulance de 8 heures le
matin jusqu'à minuit qui fait du coc
vide qui part à domicile pour faire une
prise en charge de cas suspects au vide
en plus de ça on a également mis à
disposition deux véhicules légers avec
deux secouriste à bord de chaque
véhicule qui vont faire de la levée de
doute et de l'évaluation à domicile donc
pour faire un bilan primaire secouriste
qui est retransmis au médecin régulateur
du samu et en fonction de un des
symptômes exciter le médecin va décider
si ça nécessite une évacuation sur un
centre hospitalier où si la personne
peut rester à domicile c'est rigolo
c'est un moyen de soulager les urgences
les appelle le samu j'imagine oui tout à
fait alors depuis dix jours le nombre
d'appels au samu exploser les chiffres
qu'on n'a jamais vue au niveau des
centres d'appels donc ça a permis de les
soulager de
prendre le temps de se réorganiser aussi
donc c'était quelque chose d'essentiel
et la croix-rouge avait toute sa place
dans cette mission auprès du ce yann
également aussi depuis trois jours nous
en france sont les urgences de l'hôpital
mignon où nous mettons à disposition des
secouristes mais également des étudiants
infirmiers de notre institut un fermier
à mantes la jolie
du coup qu'ils n'ont plus écoles et du
coup il renforce aussi les urgences de
l'hôpital de mignot avec des secouristes
pour prendre en charge toutes les
personnes suspectes du colis de 19 avec
une tante qui a été mis en place dans le
sas d urgence j'imagine que c'est un
grand nombre de bénévoles qui ont été
sollicités tout à fait c'est à peu près
de 100 bénévoles tous les jours sont
mobilisés dans le cadre de cette
opération de cette fois pour maintenir
nos actions sociales parce qu'il faut
pas oublier l'ensemble de nos
bénéficiaires contre en charge au
quotidien
il faut qu'ils puissent continuer à se
nourrir à pouvoir récupérer leur
courrier au niveau des domiciliations
donc il ya des personnes qui continue
ses actions sociales et puis toutes les
bénévoles qui sont engagés
principalement sur des missions
spécifiques aux victimes aux seins nus
comme aux urgences